[Music]
on this Tuesday night the Earth opens in
Iceland the rivers of lava and the
Potential Threat the volcano
poses Canada's prime minister on the
threat of terrorism the rise of
anti-Semitism is terrifying a global
news oneon-one with prime minister
Justin
Trudeau Canada puts the brakes on gas
powered vehicles when they'll be phased
out and what's driving concern turns and
our version of Supermarket Sweep the
holiday meal
edition three correspondents in three
cities so we need turkey who bought the
most affordable holiday
meal global national with Donna frez The
Forest of nature is on Full display in
the land of Fire and Ice after so much
Intrigue about a volcano that had been
rumbling beneath Southwest Iceland for
weeks the Earth opened overnight a
massive fiery fissure unleashing rivers
of lava good evening and thanks for
joining us the volcanic eruption is more
captivating than it is threatening it's
happening about 40 kilomet from
Iceland's Capital as Redmond Shannon
reports the lava flow and the
potentially toxic gases are being
closely
monitored on the darkest week of the
year a light show like no other lava
fountains 100 m high for tourists the
ultimate Icelandic spectacle it's just
like something from a movie for
residents the beauty is mixed with for
boing it's still amazing to see but kind
of a Bittersweet feeling in November
thousands of earthquakes opened up
cracks in the earth in this part of
Iceland authorities evacuated a town
this week there had been talk it might
be safe to return the famous Blue Lagoon
geothermal Spa even reopened we were
actually thinking wow maybe we we will
be able to have Christmas and new reive
at home that dream now dashed the lava
fissure measures about 4 kilm long one
end just 3 kilometers from the evacuated
town of grindvik even closer a power
plant and the Blue Lagoon there is a
Potential Threat to all of those things
uh we can't rule them out but they're
quite un likely at this stage that's
because of where the lava is flowing and
the walls recently built by the
government to protect the power plant
and grindvik the eruption steadily
weakened on Tuesday but Professor Thor
Thor Daron says there's no guarantee it
will end soon it might balance out or
level out at a of a low level 10 cubic
met per second or something like that
and if it levels out then it can
actually remain active for weeks to
months
experts say this eruption is very
unlikely to trigger an ash cloud similar
to the 2010 event that caused Aviation
chaos and it is hoped winds will move
any volcanic acid rain away from towns
just another day in the life of the land
of Fire and Ice Redmond Channon Global
News
[Music]
London the course of the Earth has been
frightening in China as 6.2 magnitude
Quake struck Northwestern China late
Monday more than 120 people have been
killed the strong shallow Quake took
down buildings damaged roads and
triggered landslides more than 700
people have been injured and there have
been at least nine powerful aftershocks
many people spent the night in makeshift
camps in cold temperatures dipping to
minus 13 Cel this is China's deadliest
quake in nearly a decade tens of
thousands of people have been left in
the dark after strong winds and Heavy
Rain lash parts of Atlantic
Canada severe weather knock down trees
and power lines across the Atlantic
region cutting off power to over
173,000 customers during the height of
the storm wind speeds reached over 100
kilm per hour in some areas including
parts of New Brunswick and Nova Scotia
and Western Newland it's the second time
in a week damaging gusts have pulled
down power lines across the region the
Supreme Court in the state of Colorado
has ruled former president Donald Trump
is ineligible to hold office again and
will be removed from the ballot for the
presidential primary in that state the
stunning decision raises doubts about
whether he can remain in the campaign
the court relied on a rarely used
provision that bars elected officials
from holding office if they have engaged
in Insurrection or Rebellion Trump's
team immediately said he will appeal to
the US Supreme Court calling the
decision deeply undemocratic Colorado
officials say the issue must be settled
by January 5th the deadline for printing
its primary ballots UNICEF says Gaza is
by far the most dangerous place in the
world to be a
[Music]
child alnasser hospital is the largest
fully functioning Hospital remaining in
Gaza it's also Sheltering civilians
UNICEF says it's been hit by Israeli
bombardment twice in the last 48
hours those Israeli family members of
people killed by Hamas on October 7th at
a music festival in southern Israel went
back to that site today to honor their
loved ones at least 364 people were
killed dozens of others were taken
hostage when Hamas Fighters raided that
Festival just after Dawn nearly 12 weeks
have now passed and the grief is still
raw the father of one of the victims
says he wanted to see where his son
died the life stopped at the 7 of
October and uh there is no no one
day that
you don't think of
him that attack led to Israel's Siege on
Gaza and the killing of more than 20,000
Palestinians today a un Security Council
vote on a resolution calling for a
sustainable cessation in hostilities was
delayed again because of disagreement
over words Crystal ganing
explains
a prolonged discussion teetering on an
impass a new resolution was put before
the UN Security Council calling for a
suspension of hostilities in Gaza on
humanitarian grounds as the US continues
to hold things up through a battle of
words bodies shrouded in white sheets
continue to be a sight in
Rafa since we came this morning we have
been revealing people from 6:00 a.m. we
revealed two of their
bodies at least 10 are believed to be
under the rubble as machines and workers
dig more tragic discoveries are made in
this Southern Gaza City where Millions
were told to go for their own safety
Israel says it's hit more than 22,000
targets since the start of the war and a
Slowdown does not appear to be in the
plants according to a report in The
Times of Israel quoting the defense
Minister the fighting is set to expand
to additional areas of the Gaza Strip
I'm furious I'm furious that those with
power shrug as the humanitarian
nightmares Unleashed on a million
children James Elder from UNICEF says
the fighting must stop and is calling on
world leaders to do their jobs and
ensure the protection of innocent
lives Israel claims it is working to
protect civilians and released a series
of videos highlighting strikes that were
aborted because children and civilians
were
identified the Prime Minister meanwhile
met with wounded soldiers and citizens
from the October 7th attacks as well as
some families of hostages there is anger
over Israeli soldiers killing three of
Their Own by mistake while they were
holding White Flags you'd murdered my
son twice you let the Hamas take my son
on October 7th and you killed my son on
December December
14th more than 100 Israeli captives are
believed to still be in Gaza Israel's
president says they are willing to
reopen
negotiations hamas's leadership says
first the bombardments must stop Crystal
Ganson Global News London Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau has made it
clear he believes Israel has the right
to defend itself he sat down for a year
and interview with our Ottawa bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson today they
discussed the Israel Hamas War his
leadership and National Security prime
minister Justin Trudeau is deeply
worried about the terrorist threat to
Canada from Neo-Nazi and Isis like
Terror groups the Prime Minister
addressed a story first broken by global
news about an Ottawa High School student
charged with terrorism and possession of
an explosive substance with the intent
to harm the Jewish community
the Prime Minister says the threat of
terrorism from groups seeking to
radicalize Young Canadians is quote very
very serious what we're seeing
particularly right now with the rise of
anti-Semitism uh linked to uh what's
happening overseas right now is
terrifying and it is something that we
absolutely have to act on and we are
acting on WE the arrest on the weekend
was an extremely important moment uh
where we're demonstrating that we are
doing everything we can to keep uh the
Jewish community in this country safe
and will continue to keep all
communities safe in this country I also
asked the Prime Minister about the pro
Palestinian protests that have recently
been taking place outside some
businesses and in some malls across the
country the video from those protests
has gone viral and it is controversial
protesting and sharing the legitimate
aspirations for the Palestinian people
absolutely knock yourself out we should
be doing that and free to do that
everywhere and anywhere but the
specifically making other Canadians feel
unsafe whether it's um Jewish kids on
campus uh whether it's uh whether it's
you know families wanting to celebrate
Christmas with their kids at a photo
booth uh and made to feel guilty because
uh the horrific fact that there are kids
dying overseas uh in Gaza um is is
something that that that people can be
made aware of but the aggressive and the
underlying violence in um making other
people feel unsafe in this country isn't
part of free protesting of freedom of
speech or or lawful protest I think the
police need to make sure that they are
uh arresting people who are engaged in
acts of violence uh and who are breaking
the law whether it's a a Sound Ordinance
or or uh a uh trespassing um these are
things that we do have to take seriously
because they snowball finally if you're
wondering if those poor polling numbers
have the Prime Minister rethinking his
political future he's not Justin fudo
told me that he's not giving up on
Canada and that he plans to double down
on leading the country into the next
election Donna okay Mercedes Stevenson
in Ottawa thanks and you can see the
full interview with the Prime Minister
on a special edition of the West block
this Sunday December 24th it will air
again on global on Christmas Day the
federal government is unveiling nailed
its road map to phase out the sale of
gas and Diesel passenger vehicles after
2035 you won't be able to buy new ones
anymore the regulations will require
automakers to sell 20% zero emission
cars by 2026 60% by 2030 and 100% by
2035 as Abigail Bean reports it is a big
shift and some are concerned about
affordability and a shortage of
electricity all new cars no emissions by
to ensure we don't get left behind and
that we keep driving towards the
opportunities being created and more
people are driving electric according to
statistics Canada in the third quarter
of this year the percentage of electric
vehicles registered jumped to 12.1
British Colombia and Quebec Drive the
most already meeting the 2026 goal of
20% there are real challenges to
electrification including affordability
and charg ing infrastructure the Auto
industry questions how realistic the
plan is with so far to go on
infrastructure and cost and uncertainty
around available and affordable
electricity charging at home is a
challenge for a lot of people that live
in multif family settings the government
suggests it's working on all of it with
a ramp up of charging infrastructure and
claims EVS will have price parity with
traditional cars within a decade
currently there's still a large upfront
cost difference and not everyone is
ready to plug in and I don't completely
trust them yet I could be okay with that
like if I can afford it I like my car
I'm good Canada's electric vehicle
Society calls the announcement a step in
the right direction and while
acknowledging the same concerns believes
industry private sector and government
need to work together for a fix these
rural highways where there isn't
infrastructure there's grid issues
capacity issues um and just cost issues
right like you know running cables to
the side of Highway in the middle of
nowhere is expensive the new regulations
have a credit and deficit program for
automakers who will have 3 years to
reverse deficits if they don't meet
targets the environment Minister says
after that point companies will be fined
industry is concerned penalties will end
up punishing Canadians with a shortage
of gas powerered vehicles before they're
ready or can afford to go electric
Abigail ban global news Ottawa Canada's
population is growing by record amount
statistics Canada says total population
growth over the first nine months of
this year surpassed the total growth in
any other full year Canada's population
was estimated at just over 40.5 million
people on October 1st that's an increase
of over 430,000 people during this
year's third quarter which is the
fastest pace of growth in any quarter
since 1957 stats can says the growth is
being fueled by immigration especially
the increase in non-permanent residents
in wi ineg a 17-year-old boy has been
charged with second deegree murder in
the stabbing death of a 14-year-old girl
it happened near a busy bus stop in
downtown Winnipeg last Friday afternoon
police say the girl was with three
people she knew when an argument broke
out one person pulled out a knife police
say the girl was stabbed multiple times
the suspect was arrested
yesterday the hunt for the best deal on
a holiday meal our correspondents have a
shopping list and have checked it twice
coming up who saved the most
moneyy the holiday season can drain bank
accounts especially with the cost of
some things on the rise but there is a
bit of good news Canada's annual
inflation rate was unchanged in November
it held steady at 3.1% stats Canada says
consumers paid more for recreation and
clothing but food prices increased at a
slower Pace compared with October
groceries still take a big bite out of
your finances though so so we gave three
of our reporters in three Canadian
cities a special assignment go out and
shop for the most affordable fixings for
a holiday
meal hi I'm Heidi pachic in Halifax and
I'm about to go shopping for my holiday
dinner so let's see how we do I feel
like I should get the big thing first I
start with the most expensive item one
5.5 kg frozen turkey 30 bucks go you
need bread to stuff that bird and dinner
roll
too then spices essential but expensive
you're in Atlantic Canada you need
Savory for your stuffing that wasn't bad
but time was
329 e this many potatoes a 2 lb bag of
potatoes parsnips and carrots and a $2
onion then off to the dairy aisle where
my budget had me swapping out one butter
for
another I'm no Baker so it looks like
this one for dessert apple pie at at
$7.99 I was going to keep track but
uh but that kind of didn't happen so now
I'm just going to wing it at the
checken thank
you
thanks okay I'm going to be honest I
think I underbut here in my attempts to
be frugal and on budget my total for all
this is $98 25 and I did have to get gas
to get my groceries as well so I spent
$30 on that to a total of
12825 for my grocery shopping trip for
the
holidays hi M and Toronto heading to the
Super Center to shop for a holiday feast
we're looking for good prices but we're
not skimping on quality right off the
bat I miss the speed bup theart this is
one smooth ride
oh it's how you recover right and with
the camera Now set we found our 7 kilo
turkey for
$22.48
a fancy spin of the potato bag later and
I was on
fire even though I missed most items on
the first pass I got it done I found all
the veg trimmings as well as coffee and
pie for
after and made my way to the
checkout so my grand total came out to $
9793 not a bad dinner for five or six
people and you know what they say he who
shops does not cook so happy holidays to
me and to the local charity where I'm
donating
this I'm Heather urix West in Calgary at
a $1.79 a liter your money in Alberta
certainly goes further at the
pumps but what about at the grocery
store to see if I can stretch my money
as far as it'll go let's head back to
the office
first instead of going into a store
today I'm going to shop around first
online I like to use an app called flip
to compare prices you just just type in
the item you need say turkey and you can
see all of the different sale prices
okay so we need turkey potatoes I have
all 17 items ordered some on sale so
that's always good now off to the
Walmart parking lot to do a
pickup you Pi up an order got the
groceries now back to the office to see
how I did I saved money on the turkey
with a less recognizable brand it came
in at
$24 he everything on the list from
Turkey to pie and altogether I paid
$11.53 Donna all such Thrifty Shoppers
Heather thanks and again that food isn't
going to waste it's going to be donated
to local
charities high flying reinforcements
next why the Canadian military is buying
armed
[Music]
drones the Royal Canadian Air Force is
buying a fleet of armed Reaper drones
the federal government will spend $2.5
billion doar on 11 remotely piloted
aircraft systems they're built by the US
defense contractor General atomics
they'll be stationed in Greenwood Nova
Scotia and comok BC the drones will not
routinely carry weapons during
operations in Canadian airspace they'll
be used for Coastal surveillance as well
as military and civilian operations such
as responding to fires and floods
delivery won't happen until
2028 there are reports Ukraine and is
ramping up its use of so-called vampire
drones to hunt down Russian
troops the drones are launched at night
they're fast hard to detect and designed
to carry heavy explosives Ukraine says
they were used this week on the Eastern
Front Line and forced Russian soldiers
back 15
km not just Paris that's the city of
light next how Rome is getting
lit
every neighborhood has that one house
that goes a bit nuts with their holiday
lights and when in Rome the city has
strung up something spectacular 300,000
lights stretching the entire length of
the Via del Corso the display is
dedicated to the universal theme of
Peace something to strive for in these
troubled times that is global national
for this Tuesday I'm taking some time
off for the holidays I hope you and your
loved ones are able to do the same on
behalf of the entire global national
team thanks for trusting us to bring you
the news every evening we wish you much
peace and joy over the holidays and into
2024 when I'll see you again
[Music]
bye-bye